[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on est toujours prêt à
toutes les éventualités on sait
pertinemment que les délucides il n'a
jamais abandonné donc on vit avec ça
aussi on espère que un jour peut-être la
mettre hors de sa tête ça je ne sais pas
mais pour l'instant c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose avec laquelle on vit
tout à fait
[Musique]
parfois notre nom notre vie
l'identité ne nous appartiennent plus
de plus en plus d'hommes et de femmes
sont victimes d'usurpation d'identité
à cause des nouvelles technologies de
l'ouverture des frontières et du
développement des bandes organisées
cette délinquance s'accélère je découvre
deux victimes Loïc zavier et Dalila il
me faut me poser une question à laquelle
je n'avais jamais réfléchi que
devient-on lorsque quelqu'un nous vole
notre vie
[Musique]
je m'appelle Laroche j'ai 32 ans je suis
victime de jour passer en identité
je m'appelle Dalila
j'ai 43 ans je suis victime du genre
patient d'identité
loïc-xavier Dalila deux cas parmi les
220 000 victimes d'usurpation d'identité
recensées rien qu'en France un débit
presque invisible un délic sans armes
sans haine sans violence apparente mais
un délit aux conséquences souvent
dramatiques
[Musique]
je me lève j'ai vraiment la paix en
vente de savoir ce qui va enclenbe
tomber dessus aller chercher son
courrier un geste du quotidien
un acte a priori anodin mais pour Loïc
Xavier Laroche c'est beaucoup plus que
cela c'est une angoisse j'ai quand même
une menace au-dessus de la tête
donc s'il y a toujours une appréhension
qui est là quand je descends chercher le
courrier ce matin rien à signaler mais
depuis des années loïcavier collectionne
les lettres recommandées menace
d'huissier relance de créances mise en
demeure rien ne lui était parmi à 32 ans
il a même été obligé de retourner vivre
chez ses parents
maintenant j'ai pris un couteau
à l'origine de cette situation
compliquée une usurpation d'identité
usurpation qui a détruit sa vie ce sera
pas le garçon qu'on aurait dû avoir qui
était plein de projets qui étaient
ambitieux ça donne c'était quelqu'un qui
avait un potentiel
j'aurais pu faire une très brillante
carrière je pense c'est quelqu'un de
droit et malheureusement c'est quelqu'un
qu'on a brisé complètement et il a plus
de rêve il a plus de projet pour Loïc
Xavier Laroche tout commence en 2004
lorsqu'il reçoit un appel d'une banque
située à Toulouse à 500 km de chez lui
je me souviens parfaitement du jour où
j'ai reçu un appel de Toulouse c'était
long juin 2004 à 11h15 du matin et donc
le directeur d'agence me téléphone en me
disant qu'une personne s'est présentée à
son agence pour faire transférer mes
comptes de la Loire sur la Haute-Garonne
mais qu'ils avaient refusé le transfert
compte tenu que la personne qui s'est
présentée au guichet était de couleur
noire et moi pas du tout quand
j'apprends ça je pense à un canular et
puis en fin de compte je me rends bien
compte justement que la personne qui est
au bout du fil est tout à fait
directrice d'agence bancaire que ce
qu'elle me raconte est tout à fait juste
donc c'est vrai que je suis un petit peu
abasourdi par la nouvelle mais j'y prête
pas plus attention que ça
à la suite de ce coup de téléphone Loïc
Javier est convoqué dans une succursale
de la banque j'ai été dans une petite
pièce avec donc la personne qui s'occupe
du service clientèle plus une autre et
là il me pose des questions pendant bien
deux heures ou est-ce que je vis ce que
je fais dans la vie depuis combien de
temps je suis chez eux etc donc j'avais
pris ça à l'époque limite comme une
garde à vue puisque ça y ressemblait je
ressors donc un petit peu chamboulé par
par cette rencontre et je vais déposer
plainte dans la foulée pour tentative
d'escroquerie la plainte sera classée
sans
suit pendant deux ans et demi plus rien
ne se passe et la vie de Loïc semble
reprendre son cours normal
mais les apparences sont trompeuses
mois de janvier 2007 je faisais les
soldes sur Lyon et au moment de payer je
me retrouve avec une petite phrase du
caissier qui me dit que mon compte n'est
pas provisionné je suis un petit peu
interloqué chez m'attendais sur mon
compte il y a 3000 euros et il me dit
non non vous n'avez pas d'argent sur
votre compte et puis arrive le mois de
juin ou là lorsque je vais essayer de
retirer des espèces ma carte se faire
absorber donc là je me dis effectivement
et il y a un gros souci je viens mon
agence et là j'apprends que je suis
interdit bancaire jusqu'en 2012 pour des
chèques sans provision que j'aurais fait
mais ils comprennent pas non plus compte
tenu que mes comptes sont tout à fait
approvisionnés d'après les informations
de son agence le compte courant de Loïc
Xavier Laroche et bel et bien créditeur
c'est la Banque de France qui au niveau
national a prononcé l'interdiction
bancaire
le jeune homme y est convoqué pour lui
il y a forcément un malentendu et ce
rendez-vous ne sera qu'une simple
formalité donc je vais à la Banque de
France on me demande ma pièce d'identité
que je donne et le fonctionnaire revient
avec un très grand sourire et me dit en
me tendant de documents vous êtes
toujours sûr que ce n'est pas vous
donc là je prends connaissance de
documents je vois un nom qui est bien le
mien une date de naissance qui est bien
la mienne un lieu essentiel bien mais
aussi et une banque qui n'est pas la
mienne et une adresse qui n'est pas la
mienne avec des chocs sans provision et
je dis bah écoutez c'est absolument pas
moi quand tenu que je ne vis pas à
Toulouse et d'ici si si c'est vous toute
façon il va falloir prouver que vous
n'êtes pas la personne il dit à son pour
nous c'est vous donc vous restera
interditaire donc là je vais pas dire
que je m'effondre mais ça me choque
quand même parce que je me dis mais
comment est-ce que je vais faire
pour prouver que je suis moi qui est
l'homme qui se fait passer pour
loïc-xavier Laroche d'après l'officier
de police judiciaire l'OPJ l'usure pater
vivrait en Haute-Garonne on aurait même
retrouvé son numéro de téléphone
l'OPJ qui prend ma plainte téléphone sur
Toulouse parce que un de mesures
pasteurs avait un numéro et elle tombe
sur la campagne de Monsieur
Laroche version noire et elle se fait
passer pour Pôle Emploi
l'OPGI et pose des questions donc est-ce
que Monsieur Laroche est là
s'accompagnerait pour nous non non il
travaille beaucoup et donc l'OPG lui
demande mais vous avez un petit accent
vous venez à lui répondre on vient du
Ghana la situation semble incroyable
comment cet homme apparemment d'origine
africaine a-t-il fait pour usurper
l'identité de quelqu'un qui ne vit pas
dans la même région que lui et qui n'a
jamais perdu ou qui ne s'est jamais fait
voler ses papiers d'identité
[Applaudissements]
la situation de Loïc Xavier me fait me
poser beaucoup de questions
[Musique]
Christophe nada vous êtes criminologue
quelles sont les méthodes employées
aujourd'hui pour l'usurpation d'identité
il y a plusieurs méthodes qu'on varie
avec le temps il y a quelques années
l'usurpation d'entité était surtout le
fait de quelqu'un qui était proche de la
victime quelqu'un de sa famille ou
quelqu'un avec lequel il avait vécu ou
passait beaucoup de temps à l'armée au
travail que sais-je aujourd'hui on a des
méthodes plus modernes plus dangereuses
aussi qui sont ce qu'on appelle le pack
ça vient du mot package en anglais qui
veut dire le nécessaire l'indispensable
dont on a besoin et dans ce package on
va trouver en originaux ou en copie une
carte nationale d'identité une carte
vitale des fiches de paye un permis de
conduire toutes sortes de choses qui
font que on va avoir suffisamment
d'éléments pour prétendre être la
personne dont on veut usurper l'identité
et on y trouve vous ces packages alors
on peut les acheter dans toutes les
bonnes cités
qui ont une activité criminelle en
général c'est le fait des organisations
qui font ça de façon industrielle c'est
pas artisanal du tout comme forme de
criminalité et qui vont constituer ces
packages en faisant croire qu'ils vont
offrir un emploi à des gens qui viennent
et qui laissent une copie de leurs
papiers d'identité pour avoir un emploi
X dans des
agences de location où on va déposer un
dossier pour pouvoir louer un
appartement tous ces documents qui ne
servent plus une fois que
les choses ont été contractualisées ou
non et bien elles sont réutilisées
récupérer dans les poubelles
par des gens qui vont remonter un
dossier ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que dans
les processus que je vous ai décrits il
y en a qui est en train de naître c'est
l'usurpation des identités par les
réseaux sociaux et là aujourd'hui des
gens très bien organisés très bien
outillés arrivent à récupérer des
éléments
identitaires donc des numéros de carte
bleue des
identifiants que vous allez utiliser et
ça c'est quelque part le paon de la
modernité mais bon ça existera toujours
Xavier Laroche vient de se rendre compte
qu'on a usurpé son identité mais pour
l'heure il ne trouve aucune solution
comment faire comprendre à une
administration que quelqu'un se fait
passer pour lui une question à laquelle
vont bientôt s'ajouter de très mauvaises
nouvelles
[Musique]
pour Dalila boisyla aussi l'usurpation
d'identité est devenue une compagne au
quotidienne
mais pour elle tout n'a pas commencé par
un appel de la banque c'est en
effectuant des démarches pour se marier
qu'elle découvre l'impensable en octobre
[Musique]
9h à peu près je me rends en mairie pour
me faire remettre un acte de naissance
donc je me présente et je demande à
l'officier de bien vouloir me remettre
un acte donc bien sûr je lui présente ma
pièce d'identité le livret de famille et
donc on me pose la question pourquoi la
délivrance de l'acte donc j'explique que
c'est pour constituer un dossier de
mariage et c'était la dernière pièce qui
m'a manquait et là l'officier me dit non
je peux pas vous le donner madame
puisque vous êtes déjà marié je viens
donner madame et moi je ne me suis
jamais mariée je vais seulement me
marier donc je comprends pas pourquoi ce
refus et donc elle me présente le
registre elle me dit non pour nous être
marié aux yeux de la loi française
Dalila boisyla est déjà mariée depuis 6
ans à cet instant une seule explication
possible elle est victime d'une
usurpation d'identité
comble de l'ironie elle travaille
justement à l'état civil d'une commune
voisine sans vraiment comprendre ce qui
lui arrive elle va porter plainte au
commissariat
ce qui est censé être un beau jour
devient un engrenage devient un enfer et
c'est là où on réalise que on finit la
ville ne va pas être aussi belle qu'on
le souhaitait qu'on espérait et que ça
va devenir un cauchemar je me souviens
que j'étais arrivé ici en larme parce
que bon j'étais inquiété j'avais peur et
il y avait un mélange de sentiments qui
faisait que j'ai j'étais pas bien du
tout et l'inspecteur m'a mise en
confiance et il m'a expliqué
qu'effectivement
malheureusement il y a des personnes
comme ça qui se retrouvent victimes du
jour au lendemain les jours passent et
Dalila vit dans la peur de son
usurpatrice donc elle a peur de savoir
qu'elle est ouvert des comptes qu'elle
s'est rendue propriétaire de de logement
peur qu'elle ait des enfants ont
peut-être
poursuivi pour des délit s graves
ça ça fait peur
après un mois d'angoisse Dalila reçoit
un appel du commissariat la police est
sur plusieurs pistes
[Musique]
il me présente des photos et il me
demande de
reconnaître donc certaines personnes sur
les photos donc je lui montre une
personne que je connais et il me dit bon
bah faut la madame oui la personne qui a
usurpé votre identique Dalila vient de
découvrir que son usure Patrice ne lui
est pas totalement inconnu
c'est une personne qui habite ma commune
c'est une personne que
j'ai pu rencontrer une ou deux fois
c'est une petite commune donc on connaît
les habitants de la commune mais Dalila
n'est pas au bout de ses surprises
sur Patrice n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai elle a affaire à une récidiviste
l'inspecteur qui me dit vous savez un
bruit Islam vous êtes pas sa première
victime vous êtes sa troisième victime
donc cela veut dire que sa pratique
arrive à déjouer toute la vigilance des
administrations et autres
l'inspecteur m'explique qu'il y a un
mandat d'arrêt international qui est
lancé à l'encontre de cette personne
donc on a des preuves mais la personne
on l'a pas elle n'a pas été arrêtée il y
a des recherches pour ma propre sécurité
il me demande de ne pas quitter le
territoire français
donc en quelque sorte je vais être
assigné à résidence non seulement Dalila
est condamné à rester en France tant que
l'on n'aura pas mis la main sur son
usurpatrice mais en plus désormais elle
vit la boule au ventre
Christophe tant que l'usurpateur n'a pas
été appréhendé on est dans l'angoisse
d'un éventuel méfait et même après qu'il
était appréhendé et aujourd'hui on a
déjà un premier problème c'est que
l'usurpation identité n'existait pas
juridiquement avant 2011 donc déjà si
vous voulez on a un manque de pratique
judiciaire et un manque de compétences
policières en matière de criminalité
identitaire on ne sait pas faire dans la
police et on ne sait pas faire dans la
justice et même quand on interpelle
l'usurpateur en question et bien il
n'est pas inquiété avant un certain
nombre de mois ou d'années et selon la
loi que risque au maximum à une
usurpateur alors aujourd'hui un
usurpateur
selon la loi risque une année de prison
ferme et une grosse amende quand on sait
que les peines prononcées qui sont
inférieures à une année ne sont pas
exécutoires évidemment c'est pas grand
chose c'est pas grand chose
on parle de la France mais en Amérique
du Nord au Canada notamment c'est une
infraction qui est considérée comme
criminel parce que c'est une atteinte
aux personnes et donc là on risque 10
ans d'emprisonnement ce qui me semble
être une sanction plus en adéquation
avec la souffrance des personnes et des
victimes
au début de l'année 1999
Dalila goezzilla connaît l'identité de
son usurpatrice elle a pu enfin mettre
un nom et un visage sur la femme qui lui
a volé sa vie et qui a empêché son
mariage
elle pense en toute logique que ces
problèmes vont se régler rapidement
elle se trompe
[Musique]
trois ans après le premier appel de sa
banque Loïc Xavier Laroche doit accepter
au jour le jour qu'un autre se fait
passer pour lui
il réalise à ses dépens que l'usure
passion d'identité ne se limite pas à
voler le nom de quelqu'un
il se fait voler une autre donnée
précieuse et intime son numéro de
sécurité sociale
les conséquences sont dramatiques en
novembre 2007 je me retrouve avoir des
problèmes au niveau de la sécurité
sociale notamment une double affiliation
les mois passent au mois d'août 2008 je
me retrouve sans couverture sociale je
suis radis je suis radier au motif que
je ne vis pas en Rhône-Alpes mais sur la
Haute-Garonne autrement dit Loïc Xavier
Laroche ne peut plus se faire rembourser
le moindre frais médical et ses ennuis
ne s'arrêtent pas là
au mois de février je commence à avoir
des ennuis au niveau des impôts qui se
rappelle à moi qui me demande un
relèvement de mon taux d'imposition dont
je me retrouve à avoir déclaré quasiment
30 000 euros sur l'année je trouve ce
qui est tout à fait exact
selon cette déclaration Loïc aurait
gagné environ 2500 euros par mois alors
qu'à l'époque il est sans emploi
déclaration de revenus double
affiliation à la sécurité sociale tous
laisse désormais penser que l'usurpateur
ne serait pas un simple escroc mais
plutôt un sans-papier
sans papier dont l'objectif consisterait
à essayer de vivre sur le territoire
français comme n'importe quel citoyen
donc un bras de fer s'engage avec
l'administration fiscale au niveau de
Toulouse
je reçois un autre recommandé au mois de
février qui me demande des sommes au
niveau de l'impôt sur le revenu et taxe
d'habitation qui n'ont jamais été payées
par mes usurpateurs à Toulouse mais
maintenant qu'ils sont majorés donc qui
c'est je crois 300 euros
je prends contact avec la trésorerie
Toulouse bien entendu qui qui ne croit
pas
à tel endroit à Toulouse bah écoutez non
[Musique]
réclame des comptes donc après je me
retrouve toujours au mois de février
avec les huiles essais sur le dos parce
que mes usurpateurs ont contracté des
crédits avec des organismes qui n'ont
pas honoré au début de l'année 200 Loïc
doit plus de 8000 euros à l'ensemble de
ces créanciers un véritable cauchemar
pour ce jeune homme sans ressource
pourtant cinq ans après le début de ses
ennuis une lettre fait renaître l'espoir
c'est une convocation de la police elle
disposerait de nouvelles informations
en 2009 j'étais convoqué par la police
aux frontières pendant 4 heures qui
avait été mandaté par mystère
d'intérieur à l'époque la première chose
que me dit la personne qui qui va
m'interroger lorsque je pénètre dans le
bureau puis effectivement vous ne vous
ressemblez pas du tout et il me tend un
papier là je vois sur la pièce
d'identité mon nom mon prénom une
ceinture qui n'est pas la mienne et une
tête forcément qui n'est pas la mienne
Loïc se croit tirer d'affaires
il ignore alors qu'une erreur
administrative va avoir de fâcheuses
conséquences pour lui
plusieurs années après avoir découvert
l'usurpation de son identité Loïc Xavier
Laroche décide en effet de partir en
vacances au Canada
et une très mauvaise surprise va
l'attendre à la douane je suis parti à
l'étranger et j'ai été arrêté à
l'aller-retour à l'origine de ces
problèmes un oubli lors de la rédaction
du mandat d'arrêt international
à aucun moment il n'est précisé que
l'usurpateur est de couleur noire et que
la victime est blanche
une situation
ubuesque Loïc Xavier Laroche a été
arrêté suite à une plainte qu'il a
lui-même déposé
de mon passeport de ma pièce d'identité
je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont appelé alors est-ce
que c'est lui est-ce que c'est pas lui
donc l'eau est noir lui est blanc est-ce
qu'on laisse passer ce qu'on laisse pas
passer et puis ils m'ont laissé passer
Christophe
ont avec ce voyage au Canada et le fait
que Loïc Xavier Laroche soit arrêtée
pour une plainte qu'il a lui-même déposé
l'usurpation d'identité est un
casse-tête juridique oui dans le cas
présent pourquoi est-il arrêté parce que
la plainte policièrement a été mal
rédigée il suffisait d'indiquer qui
était l'usurpateur quels étaient ses
caractéristiques biométriques et quelles
étaient les caractéristiques
biométriques de la victime et à partir
de ce moment-là il y avait pas de
confusion possible on savait tout de
suite qu'il était victime mais ce cas
n'est pas rare beaucoup de personnes qui
sont des victimes sont contrôlées comme
si elles étaient l'auteur de
l'infraction elle-même ça rend la vie
totalement impossible parce que vous
osez plus rien faire puis voyager puis
sortir et puis vous avez toujours peur
de la confrontation avec la police ou
avec les gendarmes en plus on a
l'impression qu'il n'y a aucune
coordination entre les entre les pays
alors c'est plus qu'une impression c'est
une réalité c'est il y a pas de
coordination parce que ce ne sont pas
des sujets qui sont aujourd'hui
considérés comme prioritaire pourtant
ils sont de plus en plus importants pas
seulement en France dans toute l'Europe
en Amérique du Nord dans les pays
développés et dernière nouveauté on
s'aperçoit que ça existe de plus en plus
aujourd'hui dans les pays en voie de
développement au Sénégal au Bénin
au Congo on a de plus en plus de gens
qui de là-bas se font usurper leur
identité parce qu'ils ont un lien
souvent avec l'Europe
[Musique]
Dalila connaît désormais l'identité de
son usurpatrice
elle engage logiquement une procédure
judiciaire pour elle cela ne fait plus
aucun doute
mon cauchemar est sur le point de
prendre fin
je confiante parce que je me dis c'est
une instruction qui va être rapide et là
je descends parce que ça n'est pas du
tout le cas
face à la lenteur de la justice Dalila
s'enferme peu à peu
sa vie ne tourne plus qu'autour de son
combat
en attendant le procès de son
usurpatrice Dalila s'isole je n'étais
plus la même et on se dit que de toute
manière quoi que l'on fasse on ne peut
plus vivre comme avant on ne peut pas
espérer couler des moments paisibles
c'est faux donc il y a un combat et ce
combat
je l'ai vécu seule un combat qui coûtera
son couple à Dabila en 2001 se sentant
exclu l'homme avec lequel elle devait se
marier la quitte pourquoi parce que
c'est sans cesse travailler c'est faire
appel aux médias
pour une instruction qui avance pas donc
ce côté de femme discrète que j'étais je
suis devenue femme publique et ça il
arrive un moment où dans le couple ça ne
peut plus aller j'ai sacrifié
malheureusement ma famille
[Musique]
pour pouvoir me défendre mais je veux
dire que si le couple n'est plus
aujourd'hui ce sont les conséquences de
l'usurpation qui ont fait que
vous êtes psychiatre on a l'impression
quand on entend ses témoignages que les
victimes du surpassion d'identité
finissent par s'isoler dans leur drame
comment l'expliquer ils se sentent seuls
contre le reste du monde c'est presque
un sentiment en paranoïaque il faut bien
le dire c'est-à-dire tout le monde est
personne ne peut me comprendre tout le
monde est contre moi et ça s'explique
très bien par le fait que c'est leur
identité qui est touché qu'est-ce qui
peut nous rendre plus fou entre
guillemets que d'avoir l'idée qu'on
croit même plus que vous êtes celui que
vous êtes c'est déjà assez compliqué de
construire son identité je suis Monsieur
Pierre Dupont je suis né à tel endroit
j'étais là j'étais allé telle
caractéristique j'étais l'adresse et
tout à coup on vous dit ben non vous
êtes pas cette personne là vous êtes
quelqu'un d'autre ou c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui est vous peut imaginer que
c'est un facilement absolument colossal
de la réalité autour de soi donc si on
peut plus s'accrocher à la réalité ça
veut dire que soit on est fou soit que
le monde est fou c'est à dire qu'il y a
quelque chose de complètement dingue qui
est en train de se passer autour de vous
et on sent bien que les victimes elles
aussi entre ces deux positions elles
finissent par se retourne contre elle
déprime elle pense même à se supprimer à
se suicider tellement ses sentiments
sont forts c'est-à-dire soit tout le
monde est ligué contre moi soit c'est
moi qui c'est moi qui ne fait pas ça
dépasse largement le problème
administratif
parfois même l'entourage de ces victimes
d'usurpation d'identité ont du mal à
comprendre effectivement l'entourage a
du mal à comprendre jusqu'à quel point
ça affecte la personne jusqu'au plus
profond d'elle-même parce que son
entourage les parents la famille les
amis savent bien que Pierre Dupont c'est
Pierre Dupont donc voilà on va pas en
faire toute une histoire c'est un c'est
un problème administratif ça va se
régler mais pour la personne qui est
atteinte c'est beaucoup plus profond
parce que c'est la confiance qu'il a en
lui il a confiance d'être lui qui est
atteinte à travers cette histoire
la confiance Dalila en manque
sérieusement à cette époque
pourtant c'est avec courage qu'elle va
affronter seul le procès qui arrive
[Musique]
en lutte avec de multiples organismes et
administrations
loïc-xavier Laroche voit sa vie gâchée
par l'usurpation d'identité il ne peut
plus voyager à l'étranger il ne peut
plus travailler il est même contraint de
retourner vivre chez ses parents
difficile de trouver un équilibre dans
ces conditions je vais très bien mon nom
ne sera pas parler après je vais
remonter je vais redescendre donc je
vais pas dire que c'est comme quelqu'un
qui souffre de bipolarité mais voilà
phase active ou non si c'est ça
[Musique]
Louis Xavier Laroche est au bout du
rouleau
ils sont alors au pire
seul contre un système et ce système mon
fond ça me bûche chaque jour c'est vrai
qu'au niveau psychologique et moral ça
fait beaucoup mais vraiment beaucoup
donc je
perds pieds on va dire ça comme ça et je
veux me suicider au mois de mai 2009
on avait vu qu'il se coupait de ses amis
il avait plus de messages j'avais plus
rien à me sentais plus de sa chambre il
ne s'alimentait plus non plus donc c'est
vrai qu'on savait que la situation elle
était moins grave on avait beau qu'à la
porte et c'est vrai qu'il ne répondait
pas et puis un jour j'ai forcé la porte
qui était pas très content d'ailleurs
mais c'était pas grave fallait que je le
vois et c'est vrai que j'ai vu quelqu'un
qui était très déterminé très calme très
zen très fatiguée aussi très blanc et
qui était déjà tout à fait détaché de la
vie et j'avais beau lui expliquer qu'il
fallait qu'il reste en vie qu'on les met
ça ne le touchait pas
pour lui non il avait pris sa décision
il pensait que sa vie elle était
complètement ratée
c'est vrai qu'on est toujours prêt à
toutes les éventualités on fait partie
d'un manque l'idée du suicide il n'a
jamais abandonné donc on vit avec ça
aussi on espère que un jour peut-être la
mettre hors de sa tête ça je ne sais pas
mais pour l'instant c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose avec laquelle on vit
cela fait cinq ans maintenant que Loïc
xavier est revenu vivre dans
l'appartement de ses parents
5 ans qu'il dort dans la chambre qu'il
occupait quand il était enfant une
situation qu'il vit très mal
j'ai envie de rentrer chez moi et non
pas chez mes parents parce que c'est pas
une chose à 32 ans qui est normal ça a
été une pièce que j'ai toujours eu qui
m'appartenait maintenant j'aimerais
qu'il n'aime pas partir plus enfin plus
comme ça j'aime bien y venir de temps en
temps mais pas mais vivre au quotidien
je vis ici contraint et forcé je vais
pas dire que je me sens prisonnier mais
c'est ça même si ça peut paraître comme
comme un cocon ça ressemble aussi à une
prison c'est l'ensemble de mon existence
qui est une prison
Serge quand on nous la vole cette
identité pourquoi c'est si difficile de
se la réapproprier parce que une fois
que c'est volé ça veut dire que ah il y
a un doute ça paraît un peu irrationnel
mais il y a un doute qui s'est installé
en vous parce que finalement il y a des
administrations il y a des institutions
les unes après les autres qui vous
disent ben non vous n'êtes pas cette
personne là cette personne là c'est
quelqu'un d'autre on croit a priori aux
administrations aux institutions qui
nous entourent on n'y croit peut-être
même plus qu'un autre propre croyances
donc ce doute là tout à fait irrationnel
qui s'est glissé à l'intérieur de vous
peut-être que je ne suis pas cette
personne que j'ai toujours cru être et
bien c'est comme un poison c'est comme
un venin qui s'infiltre et qu'il est
dont il est très difficile de se
débarrasser
[Musique]
face à ce poison le seul moyen de tenir
pour Loïc Xavier ce sont les
antidépresseurs et les anxiolytiques un
traitement qui l'aide mais l'affaiblit
physiquement
dans de telles conditions
difficiles de trouver un emploi
alors il y a 2 ans son père pourtant
retraité prend une décision radicale
il achète une auto-école pour que son
fils reprenne le travail
j'ai racheté l'auto-école la longe
devrait à la retraite mais bon il faut
donner un coup de main on va pas le
laisser tomber non plus donc pour moi
c'est c'est un plaisir
d'embaucher mon fils pour le travail je
m'occupe de tout ce qui gestion
administrative relation avec les clients
relation est à sous-préfecture avec la
préfecture le téléphone la partie
administrative je pense que l'auto-école
c'est un bon point ça permet de vivre
autrement et de pas rester inactif
surtout l'inactivité ça c'est mortelle
donc il fait le déplacement il y a son
travail il sait ce qui ce qui doit faire
donc ça permet de moins cogiter quoi
disons ce n'est pas quelque chose que
j'ai choisi de travailler ici ça m'a
permis d'avoir un emploi de changer les
idées mais c'est pas du tout quelque
chose que je compte faire indéfiniment
ce n'est pas du tout ma voix
[Musique]
en 2001 s’ouvre le procès de
l'usurpatrice de Dalila bouzilla
l'accusé est absente mais Dalila en
apprend plus sur elle je découvre que
elle a un passé assez tumultueux et donc
là je
me pose des questions et je me dis mais
va-t-on la retrouver va-t-on la
retrouver
va-t-elle répondre
aux questions et me dire le pourquoi de
cette
usurpation
la justice finit par retrouver la trace
de l'usurpatrice surprise elle est déjà
en prison pour des faits similaires
le mois qui suit donc l'avocat m'appelle
en me disant qu'elle a été localisée
mais qu'elle est incarcérée et donc là
elle est transférée au tribunal de
Valenciennes pour répondre du chef
d'accusation malheureusement pour Dalila
ce procès est une frustration
interrogée l'usure Patrice ni en bloc
lorsque le magistrat lui pose la
question de cette usurpation et
être l'auteur des faits donc elle ne
donne pas d'explication et elle dit que
ce n'est pas elle
l'usurpatrice a été condamné avec six
mois de sursis pour prise du nom d'un
tiers si le verdict quel juge léger de
la satisfait pas Dalila obtient tout de
même une réponse sur ce qui aurait
motivé son usurpatrice
cette dernière aurait pris son identité
pour contracter un mariage blanc avec un
sans-papier une union illégale qui lui
aurait rapporté la somme de 1500 euros
[Musique]
Christophe Laudun est motivation de
l'usurpation d'identité sont-elles
uniquement crapuleuses non elles sont
pas essentiellement crapuleuses mais
elle passe systématiquement par le crime
vous avez deux types de motivation vous
avez les gens qui sont en situation
régulière sur le territoire national et
donc ces personnes à un moment donné
veulent vivre dans notre pays en ayant
une vie normale et donc elles vont
passer par le crime organisé pour
obtenir des papiers et puis une fois
qu'elles en ont on en entendra plus
parler parce qu'elles auront une vie
normale ce sont des personnes qui n'ont
pas une culture criminelle et puis vous
avez une autre partie des cas où c'est
purement crapuleux c'est à dire
plusieurs personnes d'identité et
destinée à faire de l'argent de l'argent
sale rapidement générer des dettes qui
vont aller sur quelqu'un d'autre
en faisant des emprunts on se mariant
refuser ses responsabilités faites
des enfants à une femme sous un faux nom
quand vous partez évidemment elle pourra
pas vous retrouver ni vous faire payer
une pension alimentaire il y a pas
uniquement un phénomène on va dire pénal
il y a un phénomène civil qui est très
très grave parce qu'à mon avis il
déstabilise la société de droit dans
laquelle nous sommes et les droits des
individus avant tout c'est que l'État
puisse leur assurer leur identité
cela fait maintenant 10 ans que Dalila
brésila se bat pour que les pouvoirs
publics reconnaissent plusieurs passions
d'identité comme un crime à part entière
un crime qui selon elle doit être
sanctionné à sa juste mesure
elle voudrait que les peines soient
beaucoup plus lourdes plus dissuasive
mais son nouvel avocat lui préfère être
renouvellement très Dalida essayez vous
obtenir que ce soit plus très
franchement je pense qu'on aura des
difficultés parce que il faut qu'il y
ait une gradation des peines bon vous
comme vous subissez la victime a
toujours tendance à vouloir aggraver le
sort de l'usurpateur ou de la personne
qui a commis une infraction du
délinquant bon c'est logique c'est
normal c'est humain mais le législateur
lui doit établir une échelle entre le
crime de sang et l'usurpation d'identité
il y a quand même un monde et donc ça
explique que il se soit limité à un an
cela dit un an d'emprisonnement ça
représente quand même 365 jours alors je
sais bien qu'il y a des remises de peine
mais quand même c'est pas une peine
anodine c'est pas trois semaines un mois
mais Dalila n'est pas satisfaite puisque
la répression ne suffit pas elle a
décidé d'agir et c'est vers les victimes
qu'elle va se tourner
[Musique]
comme chaque weekend Loïc zavier Laroche
prend sa voiture pour aller à Lyon
dans ce quartier qu'il affectionne il
retrouve Christian son meilleur ami
[Musique]
moi je le vois de suite quand il va pas
bien bon voilà dis-moi ce qui ne va pas
et puis bon effectivement oui il y a
qu'un truc qui va pas
enfin voilà après tous ces engrenages
qu'il y a moi ça me
je sais pas comment il fait quoi on a
aucun pouvoir tout ce qu'on peut faire
c'est être là pour lui c'est tout on a
aucun pouvoir
c'est important on va boire un coup on
va au cinéma voilà il faut il faut
changer les idées
malgré ses amis malgré ses parents
aujourd'hui loïcavier vit avec la peur
au ventre
fragilisé psychologiquement le jeune
homme garde tout de même une lueur
d'espoir
aujourd'hui il a rendez-vous avec un
nouvel avocat
[Musique]
capitale pour lui
j'attends peut-être que mon avocat
mesure la gravité de la situation je
veux dire que je le vois comme mon
Sauveur quelqu'un qui qui vraiment se
donne les moyens et me permet justement
d'avoir un espoir bonjour monsieur la
roche
un dossier comme celui-là on le gagne
sur le juridique on gagne sur médiatique
et on gagne sur le politique il faut que
votre dossier
soit l'occasion d'un
débat national et sur l'occasion d'une
prise de conscience par les pouvoirs
publics et par l'opinion l'opinion
publique lorsque je lis la presse
quotidienne régionale lorsque je lis la
presse généraliste je ne vois pas de
début de prise de conscience et notre
rôle aujourd'hui avec Monsieur Laroche
c'est aussi de d'interpeller l'opinion
publique sur ces sur ces questions là
parce que effectivement il faut une plus
grande répression de ce type de délit
mais il faut aussi peut-être savoir
acquérir en sa qualité de citoyens
certains réflexes pour éviter d'être
victimes une usurpation d'identité
réflexe en matière de conservation
données personnelles réflexe lorsque
j'ai des papiers d'identité qui sont
périmés je ne vais pas les jeter à la
poubelle voilà voilà des réflexes à
acquérir pour essayer de cette nouvelle
forme de délinquance
est-ce que l'avenir avec les avancées
technologiques on peut avoir peur qu'il
y ait de plus en plus de vol d'identité
ou au contraire on peut être rassuré
qu'il y en aura de moins en moins alors
l'avenir
devrait être meilleur si demain on met
en place le contrôle biométrique
c'est-à-dire un contrôle qui est très
fiable on pourra ni voler niurper ni
substituer une identité donc je
considère que c'est un progrès parce que
ça va stabiliser la société et ça va
aussi augmenter les libertés
individuelles collective à partir du
moment où on est certain de l'identité
des gens on a plus besoin de la
contrôler toutes les 5 minutes
de son côté c'est sur le terrain que
Dalila brésila mène son combat
pour se faire entendre elle a même créé
l'association on a volé mon identité la
première du genre en France
en tant qu'officier d'état civil Dalila
a sollicité l'aide de son propre patron
le maire de la ville de Vieux-Condé
la fameuse circulaire par lequel le
gouvernement me fait une proposition
d'apposer une mention victime du
surpassion d'identité en marge de mon
acte de naissance d'accord c'est un
premier pas
j'étais confus un peu je sais pas
comment comment l'aider je lui ai dit
bah écoute voilà la mairie est un
moi-même la mérite à des disposition
finalement pour te permettre d'avancer
dans tes dans tes démarches
[Musique]
on la soutient on l'encourage c'est même
Olivier le monsieur informatique de
l'hôtel de ville qui est en train de
créer le site internet de l'association
justement cet après-midi ils ont
rendez-vous pour discuter du contenu
il y a quelques petites données à
récupérer encore tu vois et la
possibilité par rapport au témoignages
justement que de contacter avec un peu
moins un petit formulaire tu vois le
contenu c'est davantage effectivement
une discussion que j'ai avec Dalida qui
m'oriente justement parce que il y a
quand même pléthore d'information sur le
web à ce niveau là et il faut faire un
tri de sorte à ce que effectivement les
gens qui vont se balader sur le site se
perdent pas en conjecture inutile et
trouve véritablement les informations
qui leur faut et en tout cas une piste
de solution
mais le travail de Dalila ne s'arrête
pas aux heures
de lorsqu'elle rentre chez elle
[Musique]
chaque soir elle passe plusieurs heures
sur Internet ou au téléphone aller
soutenir et à les conseiller je pense
que ça va être important pour lui de
savoir où en est-il au niveau
psychologique ça donne quoi merci il a
repris un peu le dessus par rapport à
cette histoire
à peu près on va dire et puis bon à son
moral est toujours question il suffit
pas grand chose
donc en perturbé pour comprendre une
victime d'usurpation d'identité il faut
être victime soi-même
parce que une personne
qui n'a jamais été victime ne peut pas
comprendre
ce sentiment se ressenti toutes ces
conséquences ils ne peuvent pas imaginer
ce qu'est la vie aujourd'hui d'une
victime
[Musique]
mais la prise de conscience qu'elle
espère à travers toute la France n'est
pas encore au rendez-vous
ça fait
14 ans que je m'abat 14 ans c'est pas
rien et c'est 14 ans qui ont été
consacrés que pour pour comprendre pour
savoir
et c'est 14 ans ou je ne les ai pas vu
passer je n'ai pas profité de tous ces
plaisirs de la vie c'est 14 ans que l'on
m'a pris
que l'on m'a volé ce qu'il faut se dire
c'est que on en sortira pas une dame de
cette histoire donc on est meurtri mais
on est meurtri un chemin
si une grande partie des problèmes qui a
opposé Loïc Javier aux administrations a
été réglée tant que son usurpateur sera
en liberté il ne pourra pas retrouver la
sérénité je n'ai pas de documents qui me
disent voilà vous êtes lavé de tout donc
je suis lavé de rien donc tout est en
suspent tout je n'ai aucune avancée et
je n'ai absolument rien qui me dédouane
de quoi que ce soit donc demain ou même
aujourd'hui je peux de nouveau avoir des
ennuis
mais aussi à obtenir réparation pour
tous les dommages subis des traumatismes
qui laisseront des traces indélébiles
infligé quelque chose que je ne souhaite
même pas mon pire ennemi si j'en ai un
ce sont des choses que je n'oublierai
jamais jamais
[Musique]